dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here do you
remember the amazing pics to pix
algorithm from last year it was able to
perform image translation which means
that it could take a day time image and
translate it into a night time image
create maps from satellite images or
create photorealistic shoes
from crude drawings I remember that I
almost fell off the chair when I first
seen the results but this new algorithm
takes it up a notch and transforms these
edge maps into human faces not only that
but it also animates them in time as you
see here it also takes into
consideration the fact that the same
edges may result in many different faces
and therefore it is also willing to give
us more of these options if I fell out
of the chair for the still image version
I don't really know what the appropriate
reaction would be to this it can also
take the crude map of labels where each
color corresponds to one object class
such as roads cars or buildings and it
follows how our labels evolve in time
and creates an animation out of it we
can also change the meaning of our
labels easily for instance in the lower
left you see how the buildings are now
suddenly transformed to trees or we can
also change the trees to become
buildings
do you remember motion transfer from a
couple of videos ago it can do a similar
variant of that too and even synthesizes
the shadows around the character in a
reasonably correct manner as you see the
temporal coherence of this technique is
second to none which means that it
remembers what it did with past images
and doesn't do anything drastically
different for the next frame and
therefore generates smoother videos this
is very apparent especially when
juxtaposed with the previous Peaks to
Peaks method so there are three key
differences from the previous technique
to achieve this one the original
architecture uses a generator network to
create images where there is also a
separate discriminator network that
judges its work and teaches it to do
better instead this work uses two
discriminator neural networks one checks
whether the images look good
one by one and one more discriminator
for overlooking whether the sequence of
these images would pass as a video this
discriminator cracks down on the
generator network if it creates
sequences that are not temporally
coherent and this is why we have minimal
flickering in the output videos
fantastic idea to to ease the training
process it also does it progressively
which means that the network is first
faced with an easier version of the
problem that progressively gets harder
over time if you have a look at the
paper you will see that the training is
both progressive in terms of space and
time I love this idea 2/3 it also uses a
flow map that describes the changes that
took place since the previous frame note
that these previous peaks to Peaks
algorithm was published in 2017 a little
more than a year ago I think that is a
good taste of the pace of progress in
machine learning research up to 2k
resolution 30 seconds of video and the
source code is also available
congratulations folks this paper is
something else thanks for watching and
for your generous support now see you
next time